given the superhero genre is as known
for its eye-catching costumes as its
action it should come as no surprise
that birds of praise aesthetic is rooted
in the comics but how did the birds of
the screen compare to the birds of the
page clothes make a statement and the
statement shouted by Harley Quinn's
outfit is that more is most definitely
more necklaces heavy with charms acid
yellow overalls transparent plastic
motorcycle jackets heavy with fringe and
a galaxy's worth of patterns colors and
textures they're all in our closet and
vensim Harley never met a color she
didn't like piles on jewelry by the
pound and power clashes on principle if
there is a unifying factor to her
wardrobe it is her love of contrasting
the traditionally feminine against the
rugged pigtails red lipstick and
ostentatious jewelry sit alongside
ragged cut-offs stick and poke tattoos
and smeared eyeshadow the Harley Quinn
of cartoons and comics however sports a
very different look her debut in the
batman the animated series episode
Joker's favor established what was to be
the characters dominant design for years
to come a sleek unitard in red and black
it's pattern echoing traditional jesters
costumes that costume endures to this
day though recent DC Comics have
expanded her wardrobe fairly
dramatically if a dominant look has
emerged
it's the roller derby inspired design
created by artist Amanda Connor for the
characters 2014 solo series even that
outfit retains the red and black of the
1992 design however marking the
cinematic Harley as having a truly
unique look
birds of praise Black Canary sports a
look as intimidating as it is cool
onstage she is swathed in black fabric
her hair framing her face with a
dramatic curtain of bronze elsewhere she
dons a gold crop top high-waisted pants
and a plethora of accessories she's a
little bit Punk a little bit glam and a
little bit goth and in combining them
all with a toss of her hair entirely her
own brand of cool the Black Canary of
the comics is among the best-dressed of
the DC Universe as well yet in very
different fashion the characters most
well-known look features a black leotard
jacket fishnet tights and boots it's a
costume that can lean more or less moto
chic raid punk or pristine bombshell
depending on the situation though it's
starkly different from her movie duds
its spirit is similar striking stylish
versatile fashion for a woman as
comfortable in the streets as she is on
the stage
black mask isn't into subtlety he is
after all Lord of his club bound Kingdom
why not shake up the typical business
man's wardrobe his suits might be as
well cut as any bankers but he has them
made in green velvet and floral prints
paired with monogrammed gloves and vivid
pocket squares there's a flamboyant to
the villain rooted in his success he
dresses according to his own taste
because he's built a world in which his
tastes are the only ones that matter the
black mask of the comics in contrast
sticks to the classics his suits are
beautifully made but largely understated
if he branches out it's by wearing
pinstripes a double-breasted cut or a
simple pocket square this understated
canvas highlights the true departure of
his design the black mask he takes his
name from carved from the ebony wood of
his father's coffin he is rarely seen
without it he's a terrifying man who
lives to see his enemies their cronies
and more than a few innocent bystanders
suffer beneath his thumb not the kind of
dude to experiment with sunglasses but
very much the sort to enjoy trading his
normal face in for a terrifyingly
inhuman facade birds of praise Victor
Zsasz looks like the consummate creep
his clothes aren't much to look at but
the way he wears them says it all he
slouches smears and never seems to be
without a knife hidden in one of his
many pockets all the better to brandish
at the birds add in a bleached crop of
hair and prominent facial scars and he
looks every inch the violent enforcer of
black masks sinister intentions that he
is the Victor Zsasz of the comics is
similarly unpleasant but two very
different ends he's painfully thin often
shirtless and absolutely covered in
tally marks one for each life he's
claimed this Zsasz is a demented serial
killer and his negligible clothing
underlines this fact his eyes tend to
bulge and roll
all his teeth to clinch and manic Glee a
knife ever-present in his wiry hands the
cinematics as might look like the jerk
lurking in the alley but the comic zest
looks like he's straight out of a
nightmare the Cassandra Cain of the
birds of prey movies sports a look
typical of any skater kid you knew
growing up clothes for running hanging
out lying low her cut-offs are the
classic kind having clearly begun their
life as actual jeans she took scissors
too instead of something created in the
factory topped by layers of hoodies
t-shirts and jackets her most
distinguishing feature is the hot pink
cast on her arm crowded with doodles of
guns playing cards and other icons
she's the punk kid in every sense
deliberately ragged uninterested in
fashion and likely to be kicked out of
any given corner store for loitering do
I look like I'm worth half a million
dollars not really the comics Cassandra
Cain sports a far sleeker look each
superheroic persona she's claimed
Batgirl black bat and orphan being the
three most prominent has come clad in
black and yellow mostly fit to her body
for maximum stealth her Batgirl costume
likely still her most well known look
obscures her hair and face exchanges the
classic yellow gloves and boots for
black ones and hollows out the bat
symbol on her chest into a simple yellow
outline she's a shadow of the Gotham
skyline devastating and unstoppable in
her delivery of justice played by the
incomparable Rosie Perez birds of praise
Renee Montoya is a pillar of power our
clothes enforce this sleek slacks
button-downs and blazers all say that
this is not a woman to be messed with
her clothes are pared down to the
essentials there are no pleats at the
case or patterns to be found on Renee
Montoya the steely police officer only
offsets her look with a simple gold
chain and occasionally a pair of brass
knuckles
generally speaking the Renee of the
comics keeps things similarly simple but
there's a casual edge to her clothes
that the cinematic Renee lacks
especially when she's on the job though
Renee does wear more formal clothes now
and again she favors t-shirts jeans and
leather jackets as the question a role
renee assumed in the 2006 52 series
she keeps things a little more formal
wearing a suit tie fedora and face
obscuring mask in both universes Renee's
clothes make one thing crystal clear she
is absolutely not to be messed with
and in her practical shoes and bootcut
slacks absolutely able to chase you down
if you make an ill-advised break for it
unlike certain other members of the
birds of prey
Huntress largely sacrifices fashion for
function sure she enjoys shades of
purple crop tops and leather but she
dispenses with the piled on jewelry
prints and whimsical jackets of her
friends her look is tactical even
militaristic incorporating body armor
motorcycle gear and the movies only
utility belt with their trademark
crossbow in hand she cuts a fearsome
figure indeed which is exactly what the
ex mafia princess wants huntress
maintains a similar look in the comics
favoring purple leather and enough
pouches to keep her well stocked in
weaponry but there are also a few
theatrical details the cinematic
Huntress might fall ket most prominent
is her mask a purple affair that at its
most dramatic rises to two sharp points
above her hairline then there are the
cross motifs she's often incorporated a
whole host of crop tops and belly
cutouts quite a bit more revealing than
our movie counterparts and closets worth
of thigh high boots Huntress is never
without her crossbow signature color
scheme or a pouch or two to stow her
bolts in but that doesn't mean she's
seen no changes in her moved to the big
screen check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about comic book movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]